loved your movie
oh thank you so good and that's really
all i have
we can just call it there all right hey
this is the best interview all day
i love it being serious though uh
was this one of these ideas that you had
had for like a really long time
talk about like where when this thing
first germinated for you
yeah no it actually wasn't um i think i
think it's sort of
it reads like that i think it like it
sort of is like dripping with passion
you know like um i think everyone who
worked on the movie was really
passionate about it and stuff but but
actually the movie came
from when uh i i was talking to sony and
they were like do you have any movie
ideas i was like
i have so many movie ideas and i had
nothing i was like
i was like chick you don't want to see
what's in my pad here it's
masterpiece after masterpiece is like
blank um so um
so like uh so basically i just was
trying to
because i i'm really interested in like
personal unique
films and i was sort of like i wondered
if i could make
one of those at a at a big studio
because it's it's it's not easy to make
something personal or unique in a big
studio
but you know the people at sony were
really great and i was like well let's
try it and i sort of tried to take the
thing that i love the most which is my
crazy family
um because i think everyone thinks that
their fit secretly is like my family's
crazy but everyone else's is like kind
of cool
um but like um so and i i felt like i
was connected to people when i talked to
my family
talked about my family and talked about
like being open about us being kind of a
bunch of goofballs
um and uh and then sort of like it's
trying to sort of like um i as a child
was interested in robots because i'm
just you know i was a nerd
and i think robots are cool um and as an
adult
yeah i love it as an adult i was sort of
i'm just interested in the fact that
like
in a world where robots can do all the
things that humans can do
what what is humanity's role um
in the world and like what makes us
special as people
um so that those were like and then i
got really excited about that
idea um and sort of like tried to figure
out if i could
jam those two ideas together and it was
and it took a long time but i'm i'm
really happy with where it ended
one of the things that i loved about the
movie uh one of the many things of
course is
the way it was animated there's
obviously so many
frames that i'm going to want to push
pause on
when you were explaining to the
animators what you were trying to
accomplish
with this film and the way you wanted it
animated at any point did they
just say fu and just walk out of the
room because
it's not easy to do what you did no it's
i mean it's not but i will say the team
it was so like what you like about the
movie
is like whatever percent me and like
90 the animators and you know like
everyone on the team
like brought so much into it and they
were so
jazzed because it was sort of like
basically like i was like let's do
something new and they were all like
yeah you know because i think it's you
know
as an animator it's like kind of a crap
shoot you might get some movie that's
really exciting and you might get
something that you're
you hate um so they just i think they
liked the movie and they were excited
about it and we were excited about
like you know pushing the medium and and
and
what if we did all these things nobody
had ever done before and we're gonna
take all these animation tropes and turn
them on their heads and they got really
excited about that so they started
throwing in all their ideas
and it was great because like we were
just sort of capturing good ideas from
like this team that was awesome and a
lot of the people
on our movies started on spider-verse so
they were kind of like
my our our vfx supervisor i like to say
was like broken by spider-verse or
something like
he was like what do you got what's next
like
like you know and we would show him our
looking picture and he's like how could
it be
bolder and we're like all right i like
this guy
so it was it was cool and we were just a
bunch of you know nuts
just trying to um trying to make
something that we love
are there any easter eggs or things that
people should be
on the lookout for in this movie that
you might need to push pause on
yeah i mean there is a robot language in
the movie
uh so there um so if you care to decode
it
you might find out some stuff um and
like you know any time there was
text we tried to make it really loved up
and
and stuff because i i love that like in
the simpsons and stuff where
you know when i was a kid that was like
a magic trick i was like i have vcr i
could
pause it when this you know the names
scrolled by and there's like oh that's a
funny joke and i got it for free
um so um because it always just said to
me as an audience member like oh we're
valuing your time we're valuing your
attention
um so we wanted to like reward people's
attention that way so
there's a lot of places where you could
pause the screen and see a bunch of
weird stuff
hope it's a huge hit i am me too you're
living in god's ears thank you